My phone is dead, as usual, and.
And then I remembered I have this amazing thing.
Look, it plugs into your car.
And outlets that all cars have.
You can adjust it so even if it feels big and bulky,
it will fit in the space.
This is my favorite part.
The little cords are retractable,
so you can pull it out and give it the slack,
so it's not like pulling.
I always feel like that's gonna damage my shit.
And it's got.
It's got for apple,
for anything else,
and then it's got open spaces for other chargers.
So even though I'm not an Uber driver,
I feel like an Uber driver. As a mama.
For kids with their friends and their phones and their shit.
And this thing helps us all survive.